almost all american journalism is
controlled by a few massive corporations
news voice is a one-of-a-kind mobile app
that tracks the bias and corporate
interests that infuse the new stories we
consume every day
and it's completely free to use go to
news voice dot com
slash pacman to download it
donald trump's attorney general william
barr is now claiming
that the pepper spray used to clear the
path from the white house to saint
john's church
is quote not a chemical irritant
this is the latest version the latest
defense of the now
seven day old photo op that donald trump
did
which ended remember with donald trump
awkwardly holding a bible in front of
saint john's church last monday
we had video for you from last week of
protesters
clearly being gassed and dispersed with
horses
you can see the gas rising as protesters
flee
so the first statement the white house
put out
was no tear gas was used seemed like an
obvious lie
and indeed eventually a statement was
put out i believe by the park
service saying we were wrong when we
said
it was incorrect to say that tear gas
was not used that was not true so then
william barr
who's a completely sinister character in
this entire greek tragedy of the trump
administration
trump's attorney general general
defended
the use of what they used by saying
listen they were warned multiple times
before we started deploying the crowd
control elements like gas
and we'll pick it up there here's
william barr saying once police met
resistance from protesters
yes it was appropriate to use tear gas
to clear a path for donald trump take a
look
were appropriate when they met
resistance yes
they announced three times they didn't
move by the way there was no tear gas
used the tear gas was used sunday when
they had to clear 8th street to allow
the fire department to come in to save
st
john's church that's when tear gas was
used they were chemical irritants the
parts no they were not chemical
irritants pepper spray is not a chemical
irritant it's not chemical
pepper spray you're saying pepper bowls
right
and you believe that was appropriate so
barr says everything was justified
tear gas was not used and pepper spray
balls
are not a chemical irritant so let's go
through these claims one by one
first tear gas wasn't used local
reporters
went through the area after this fiasco
and they collected
used canisters of cm
speed heat cs and cm
scat shell oc these are two types of
tear gas now
is it possible that that was tear gas
left over
from the previous day as william barr is
claiming that the previous day sunday
not monday they used tear gas
because it's hypothetically possible
doesn't seem hugely likely
so that part barr saying tear gas wasn't
used appears to be a lie
then we get into the semantic thing tear
gas versus pepper spray
they are both chemical irritants each
uses a different
irritant pepper spray uses capsicum
which comes from the active compound in
hot peppers tear gas is a halogen
compound
that is powder like at room temperature
so in the most
technical sense these are two different
things
but the cdc classifies pepper spray as a
form of tear gas
so it becomes merely a semantic argument
now lastly
barr says pepper spray is not a chemical
irritant well it is an irritant
this issue of chemical is that
the chemical is one that exists in food
as well
it's a highly concentrated version
of the irritant in
peppers so what bar maybe is leaning on
is that it's a
natural element rather than a lab-made
chemical
but when you're talking about hot
peppers and going through a process
where you extract the irritant from the
peppers
concentrate it into a pepper spray
the fact that it's quote naturally
occurring
seems irrelevant and william barr you
know he seems to be suggesting that this
is no different than tossing some
jalapenos at protesters
this is a highly concentrated very
powerful irritant that once again the
cdc
classifies as a form of tear gas so
it's gaslighting and its deception all
around
and william barr a horribly sinister
figure
in the trump administration once again